[Music]
now that is one big pile of okay
the trailers good I am a big fan of
Jurassic Park I mean look here's the
original two novels that I have by
Michael Crichton and I of course have
lost world in Jurassic Park on blu-ray I
don't have Jurassic Park 3 Alan hey Alan
I'm a raptor Alan I really do love those
movies I mean I really I love them a lot
like I feel like Jurassic Park has
shaped me as a person in some strange
way I grew up with it it was in the 90s
it was in that one spot in my life where
I was like blossoming into what I would
become in Jurassic Park served a
humongous part of that so the trailer
for Jurassic world is out and stars
Chris Pratt Bryce Dallas Howard and Judy
Greer I'm not sure how much she will be
in the movie but she's definitely in the
trailer for a brief part I feel like she
might be like the Laura Dern in Jurassic
Park 3 role where she sends the people
off and then from time to time you know
you might cut back to her and she's
doing things and maybe Barney will be on
the television and you know I could
happen and for some reason they were
able to reopen a park for people to come
with dinosaurs and people actually go to
this place despite the three other times
where dinosaurs definitely weren't a
good idea we now have an official park
where people are going and of course bad
stuff starts to happen and Chris Pratt
seems to be like the kind of guy they
send in to figure it out in a way like
he's hunting the creature he's trying to
figure out what's going on with this
strange genetically mutated creature
that is now on the loose let's just get
my biggest issue out of the way first
I'm not buying that they actually were
able to create another park with
Dinosaurs where people go yes I will go
despite all the other people who got
mangled and killed we're gonna go to
this one I know that's why they didn't
bring like hardly any one of the
original cast back because they were
like look there are only so many ways
these original cast members are gonna go
back to a place that has dinosaurs at
this point that being said it's still
more people who are like a dinosaurs oh
no we're all dying
that's how all this starts and later
there's running and screaming but this
movie does actually look really good and
what I mean is it does look good like
the special effects look convincing
enough Chris Pratt looks awesome in the
role Bryce Dallas Howard does as well
and the direction of the movie looks
really Swift and it looks like a big
movie which is a relief to me because
the director of this film previously
directed safety not guaranteed which has
since kind of become a cult hit I kind
of feel the film's a little overrated
though so I was like really they're
gonna get this person to direct Jurassic
world which is a huge movie with so much
responsibility with so much more work to
do than a smaller film like safety not
guaranteed so I'm really hoping he's
able to pull it off and the movie does
look really great and so that's a relief
to me of course Spielberg is executive
producing the film so that is also cool
to have him involved in some way and the
trailer had this hybrid version of John
Williams piano music you're the dad one
of the best musical themes ever in a
movie so I'm hoping that that means
they're going to retain those teams
because I can't really imagine a
Jurassic Park movie without John
Williams themes the special effects look
great the hints at frightening stuff
look really good like with a shadow
coming over the kids face the Raptors
and the motorcycle I really hope that's
like an extended sequence it doesn't
look like a bunch of CGI stuff because
it looks really cool and I like the idea
of that and I do like the idea of a
genetically altered thing that's
different from everything else on the
loose and it feels like a different
thing you know it's like okay that's the
one that's not a cool one right there
that one isn't trained like SeaWorld
that one's gonna kill us
and I like the idea of Chris Pratt being
like the Muldoon badass guy who hunts it
I hope that that is more of what his
characters like because it seems like
they're hinting like that and the bushes
straight ahead but being hunted I hope
that's where his character is like that
kind of badass hunter guy who knows
about stuff and he's like the guy who
keeps trying to warn them as like that's
not a good idea
lots and lots of people were once killed
by dinosaurs that we created and you
want to go there with
people on the ground and uh the chaos
theory so now I'm by myself talking to
myself that's chaos theory that's chaos
joking aside I am so excited to see this
movie and I hope that it delivers I'm
gonna remain peacefully optimistic about
it but also a little skeptical just so I
don't get my hopes and dreams crushed
guys what are your thoughts on the
Jurassic world trailer let me know below
I'll be back very soon with review for
Horrible Bosses 2 and Super Smash
Brothers for the Wii U with a recorded
match in the review with the youtuber
that I think you guys will enjoy seeing
me verse thanks as always for watching
guys and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]